How do we charge an object? Well, there are actually several ways.
One way is we can charge by friction.
And if you've ever rubbed your feet on the carpet and then touched your friend
who was standing nearby and giving them a shock you have charged yourself by friction.
And what's going on here, the rubbing between two objects actually causes one
to steal the electrons of the others.
Now, it doesn't steal the protons because protons are well relatively
gigantic compared to electrons.
Electrons are tiny, tiny little guys.
And so it turns out that just simple rubbing can actually cause an exchange of charge
leaving one object positive and one negative.
In fact, this sort of charging happens in cumulonimbus clouds
and these are the sorts of clouds that cause lightning.
And what happens is little drops of ice or water are constantly moving around
in this cloud and as these droplets pass through the cloud rubbing against each other
and passing through different regions of the cloud they gradually either accumulate
or lose electrons depending on what they're moving on and the details
of the actual situation but what this does is it creates a motion of charge.
Whether this is positive or negative.
Whether it's going up or down. It doesn't really matter.
What happens is charge separates and what that usually leads to
is chaotic motion of particles.
There's a buildup of minus charges in the bottom of the cloud and positive charges at the top.
Now we've already shown that these minus charges
lead to corresponding positive charges building up in the ground.
We're starting to really understand lightning here as well as electricity.
We can use charging by friction to create a charged object.
Let's say we've created a positively charged ball.
A good way to do this is by rubbing something metallic with let's say rabbit fur.
Anyways we have this positively charged ball.
and we know that if we bring it near to this ball we'll induce some polarization.
Negative charges on this side and positive on that side. Fine.
But what happens if this ball touches that ball?
We bring this over and let them touch and remember they're both conductors.
All in all, what do you think will happen when I touch this ball to that?
Do you think nothing will happen?
Do you think that some positive charges will flow from ball B to ball A?
Do you think that some negative charges will flow from A to B?
Or do you think that all the positive charges on ball B will flow to ball A?
Think about what it means.
There will certainly be a conductor, and then give this question a shot.